на майдані незалежності, який на хом'як
спраги загадаю своїх цінував
Володимир той метро стояв цю на
барикадах протеїну ковач а потім прийшла
його його ти на донбас 5 ви весна 2014
за дві води на до початку пункту в
вогнем машина бити а ми їх батальйону
потро палау за сітку з протестом
апарат разом міс. щастя на
луганщині
бути постріл чому ви бух laptev по
випадав із машини
дали by короткий наскільки я знаю тіла
сепаратисти підбирала та піт повну
відпалювали офісі на волдеморт admit різні
кліпи зірки на фотографіях сина поні ви
члени в тому кутку tell які на своїх
на з знайшла експорт та відновив
дільничний в їхній день
вибухівка ми одному із загребу їх
кошти поважаючи її старшого сина загнані в
том бою
алмати вимагаючи дудаків їх до козел я
хочу здобуто себе істини я хочу зазирнув
і мій син і я видних напевно є я
їх забираю їх шивани живи я не хочу їх
пари приватних увата тимчасово ховати
якими пропускають син і праною не
йому найкращий мужик but i ухилі там розуму я
а кожного місяця
їздити злість кодак у його щоб тася
вимови бішер готель міни закладено
експертизи поки що безрезультатно так їх
яка на материк знак або заїзд
об'єктив в Україні ки до 100 і подруга
на щастя валентине богачук
смоленської області
також сир і ліжко сука я хочу я
каюся достовірної інформації про свого
сина павла зв'язки в this issue
я коен і вище в заточеного іловайська 4
захара але не повірив і
та doing an sp повний та 1 тобто. на гея США
вінда сажовий віспою scart полунін та
наїда його на багатому а тариф знакових
без участі довіряють кошти і самі
боротися за гарматою пухова не безіменних
солдат у моргах
на ж шукаю полунин їх по too big
фронту жінкою не проколюють своєю грози
на владу миша optronics бішопа щоку
villa by ship помилкою чи то пак і
заколюй вони на і кен з тішить ніколи
що може хто себе за sti зниклий
придатним за успіхи в аналогічних
зустрічаю мінську називала думала їсти з
боже кузні ікло без віз ти-то полунин їх
то воно навик він на ці обожнюють у сіті
джинкою каліц вони вже приготувати
посольство краї нормандською четвіркою
вимагають треба ти тим досвіду new особливий
статус створи ти україну групу з
пожартував хіба нині половинах